you've got to do everything you can at
once and as we come out of of covid we
we face a real cost of living crunch
caused largely by the inflationary
spikes you're seeing around the world
particularly in in energy and the
government has to help people we are
helping people just we've helped people
throughout the the pandemic and so what
rishi has announced today is a 9 billion
pound package to uh to help people with
the cost of their of their energy very
considerable support for people
and then
20 27 million households will benefit
from a council tax rebate worth 150
pounds and a 200 pound loan on top of
that so a lot of money going in now to
help people with the cost of living on
top of what we're doing uh with the
living wage with the uh the um effective
tax cuts for people on on universal
credit
but you know all this
investment all this helping people is
only going to work if we have a
sustainable
long-term
economic recovery with high-wage
high-skill jobs and so what we're doing
today
is
putting in the investment here for
instance in blackpool 22 million pounds
going into
the tram network and that is driving
thousands more jobs private sector jobs
because
we think i think that levelling up is a
fantastic mission for our country and
it's about recognizing the genius and
talent everywhere and you need to to
unleash it but you've got to have the
private sector leading it
nearly 700 pounds a year more in energy
costs that's going to be a huge hit for
many people
shouldn't the government be doing even
more to help people with those bills
that are coming down the line
so for people who are facing particular
hardship of course uh we have one and
for everybody we have uh abatements uh
things we do to help with the cost of
energy cold weather uh payments warm
homes discounts and uh and so on uh this
is a mega package a mega package of nine
billion pounds on top
which is i think you know
necessary but it's huge and that is
there to help people with this
particular spike that we're seeing right
now
what i hope and believe is that
eventually as the world economy gets its
uh back it gets its momentum back uh the
inflationary pressures will will start
to subside vital thing you've got to do
in order to help keep uh inflation under
control uh is is ease those those
problems in the supply chains get people
into work in the jobs where they're
needed so that's why we're also doing
our way to work program getting half a
million people off welfare
and into work to help ease the uh the
blockages in the uk economy get things
working more smoothly and that is
another another way that you can get
inflation under control would you look
again at the national insurance rights
given the scale of the price rises that
families are going to be facing
you've got to remember also as we come
out of covid our covid recovery plan has
got to involve dealing with the colossal
backlog that we've got in our nhs the
nhs was amazing and is amazing it's
dealt magnificently with the the
pandemic but
there are huge numbers of people six
million one in ten of the uk population
currently waiting on a uh on on an nhs
waiting list that's gonna go up i'm
afraid it's gonna it's gonna go up we've
got to put in the money uh to fix it
nine million more scans fifty thousand
more nurses uh building the hospital the
hospital capacity uh that we need it's
the number one priority of the of the
british people and uh we've gotta fund
it so i know it's it's not what anybody
wants to do it's not what rishi wants to
do it's not what i want to do but we've
got to do it on northern ireland on the
protocol will you ensure that checks on
goods are carried out which is part of
the international agreement that you
agreed and signed
i hope that we can get i know that uh
liz trust is seeing mauro sefkovic again
i think today that's great that the
conversations are continuing what we've
got to do is get to a sensible
solution that recognizes that it's crazy
to have checks on goods that are
basically circulating within the single
market of the united kingdom what you
can have
of course is a common sensical practical
steps to to weed out to check on things
that might be
at risk of circulation as they say in
brussels a risk of circulation in uh in
ireland as well as northern ireland now
we can do that but without having a full
panoply of checks uh on the the gb ni uh
coast and and at the airport and that's
the way forward i think practical common
sense is what's needed it's not going
bad going back though on what you agreed
actually if you look at the protocol
which i'm sure you have studied in
detail uh
there's plenty about uninterrupted uh
east-west trade
on your leadership your chancellor said
today that the the parties in downing
street has damaged public trust in
politicians one of the people who put a
letter in of no confidence said that
they wanted the tone of debate not
lowered and yet you made an allegation
the commas about kistama not prosecuting
jimmy savile does that not bring the
tone down so why did you make that
allegation
well i want to be very clear about this
because because a lot of people have got
uh very
hot under the collar and i i understand
why
let's be absolutely clear i'm i'm
talking not about uh the leader of the
opposition's personal um record when he
was uh when he was dpp uh and i and i
totally understand that he had nothing
to do
personally with those decisions i was
making a point
about
um
the his responsibility for the
organization
as a whole and i think people can can
see that i just i really do want to
clarify that because it is it is
important but on your wider point um
you know i think we what people want is
for us to uh to focus on the issues that
really matter for them so look at uh i'm
not saying that other issues don't
matter but above all we've got to focus
on cost of living and on taking the
country forward and i think we can
tackle both things together uh with our
program of uh support for people now
getting the uh of the kobe recovery plan
really humming uh getting people back
into work and you know the british
record on this that our country's record
on this is absolutely amazing when you
consider what we've been through as the
chancellor was saying this morning
unemployment is far far lower than where
it was predicted to be we've got record
low youth unemployment what we need to
do now is really turbocharge that and
put in the measures through leveling up
they're going to drive a long-term
sustainable high-wage high skill
jobs-led recovery the point about living
up
we think there's talent everywhere we
want to unleash it again on the issue of
your character the former chief of the
defense staff has said today people look
at you and they're not sure that they
can
trust you in terms of ukraine and the
sort of foreign issues that's a problem
isn't it
no i think the uk has played a very
important role uh so far in bringing
together the
west and making sure that our uh our
partners understand the um the severity
of the threat that the ukrainians face
and i think if you look at what we've
been doing for the last
two or three months the uk has been way
out in front in making sure that people
respond so we've been putting together
the right package of economic sanctions
it's got to be tough enough and we've
got to make sure that um
people understand it's got to be
automatic so that um there's no there's
no sort of argument uh when
uh if and when there is a russian
invasion
that those sanctions come in
automatically and as you know we've
changed the law so that the uk will
apply sanctions uh both personally but
also on
any company of strategic
russian interest number two the uk has
been out in front in supporting the
ukrainians through
uh the contribution of uh
lethal defensive weaponry and uh that's
very important we're we're one of a
handful of countries uh to do that along
with the united states lithuania and
that's something that is greatly
appreciated by ukraine helps to
fortify their their defense uh but
i think where the uk has possibly been
most
most useful of all is in in just trying
to get over to the world what a tragedy
it would be if uh such a
an invasion were to take place a tragedy
for for russia as well